Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
This is a reminder for newer people that you can chat in or if you want to verbally speak into your questions, you'll have to unmute yourself.
The way the Zoom call settings are is that everybody is muted and rival.
So if you want to ask a question verbally, you'll have to unmute yourself and then yourself again.
So we don't get feedback.
Well, first we'll answer the questions that were sent in.
So just a reminder, all announcements are on the front homepage of the member site.
Let's jump to the questions.
I've had the same right programs for quite a while.
Should it be changed? Should the programs be changed?
Well, not always. So if there are new frequencies for your type of cancer,
would you send a cheek swab in? Typically I will update your frequencies or I will test when I get your cheek swab.
But if they're or sometimes if there's new frequencies, I will let you know and send you a flash drive.
So it just depends. So if there's no new frequencies for your particular cancer,
and even doing the cheek swab testing with kinesiology, if nothing else comes up, then no, we don't do any changes.
Even if you've had the same program for a long time, I've had some people running the same program for a decade or more
because they're doing well and they're stable and they don't want to change anything.
And sometimes people ask for a change in program because they're stable and they have other comorbidities
that they want to add to their overnight.
Maybe hey could get requests like hey, can we add blood pressure to my overnight or can we add neuropathy to my overnight
because my cancer is pretty stable and I just want to start treating these other things
without having to do them during the day. So yeah, we can do that as well.
So it just depends on what your desires are.
Is there a better time of day to take by supplements?
Well, that depends on what it is that you're taking.
So better time of day to take your supplements in general is it's better to spread your supplements throughout the day.
So let's say you're taking three a day of certain supplements for most of those.
It would be better if you spread them out throughout the whole day.
Sometimes if you're taking let's say vitamin C to get a higher dose of vitamin C,
you want to take it all at once.
Remember if you take a lower dose vitamin C, let's say 1000 milligrams, you're absorbing maybe 500 milligrams of that.
That's going to be an oxidative therapy.
That's not always wise for a cancer patient.
If you're trying to get an oxidative therapy out of your vitamin C,
then maybe you're taking 5000 milligrams a day, 5 grams a day of vitamin C.
You don't want to take that all at once so that you absorb an oxidative dose.
But if you're taking things for just general cancer care or general immune stimulants,
general anti-inflammatories, you take those throughout the day because all your supplements have a half-life.
So they will dissipate out of your body quite quickly.
And then taking digestive enzymes in HCl, you take those only with a meal right before your meal right with your meal or immediately after your meal.
If you're taking an oxidative approach to melatonin, let's say you're taking high dose melatonin,
you may take that 40 milligrams in the morning and 40 milligrams in the evening.
So it depends on the supplement.
General supplements like general nutrition, general anti-inflammatories, you don't want to spread those throughout the day.
And then fat-soluble supplements, it's a little bit different as well because fat-soluble supplements you don't need to spread through the day.
You can also store in your body and you can just take them any time during the day.
Sometimes you can hyperlone on vitamin D, per se, and just take it once a week.
But typically I want people to take their vitamin D3 with their other fat-soluble vitamins that I tell you to take a lower dose every day.
Sometimes on the supplement that we're talking about and when the time of the day is better to take it.
Obviously if you're trying to take something to try to help you sleep, you take it in the evening, you know, so things like that.
So it depends on what it is that the supplement that you're trying to do with the supplement.
Are there signs of copper toxicity?
I heard that we should be using copper pans, but you said you don't agree.
That's right. I have said it in other questions, answering other people's questions in the past that I don't agree with using copper bracelets and copper pans and copper cookware.
There's a lot of quote-unquote nutritional counselors that are out there on Instagram and TikTok and Facebook that quite frankly are telling you wrong information.
This would be one of them that we should be using more copper. Copper is good for us, so we use copper pans.
Copper is a necessary nutrient for us because copper helps with growth and cell turnover, but you get your copper through your food.
So your source of copper would not be elemental copper in your copper pans or your copper pipes.
That's basically a toxic heavy metal.
The cancer patients in general don't want to be taking multiple vitamins that have copper or minerals that have copper.
Even if they're a good source of copper, shouldn't be taking anything that's a bad source of anything, but even let's say you're taking a good source double bonded to an amino acid copper, should I be taking that?
Well, not as a cancer patient because what does copper do? Copper helps stimulate growth, so you shouldn't be taking that.
And then also, even if you didn't have cancer, for the most part, most people are getting excess copper and end up with copper toxicity.
If you remember on your genetic report, we looked at your copper genes. People that have defects on your copper carrying genes can even have more issues with copper.
Copper toxicity is common. What can be what can be signs of copper toxicity?
Most common would be like headaches, fatigue, just nausea, and typically it's going to be a low dose copper toxicity that this person have.
You can end up with arthritis, rheumatoid arthritis, gaudy arthritis, as a copper toxicity sign.
And if you start taking zinc, what rule of thumb? If you start taking zinc and you feel sick, that's not an uncommon thing because zinc will push out excess copper, excess, especially excess elemental copper, it'll push it out of your cells.
If you feel sick, typically it's like a headache after taking zinc, it's a sign that you have copper toxicity, that you'll have to take some vitamin C to bind it.
So, you know, make sure you contact me. If you are taking zinc, you know, say, well, every time I take zinc, I do feel sick. I don't know, I thought I was just trying to sensitivity to zinc.
No, it's that you have a copper toxicity. So you've got to go slow to help detox the copper. So how would a person detox copper? It would be by taking zinc, but you'd also have to take a binder or a key later with it.
Vitamin C does keylate copper well, though we don't want excess vitamin C as cancer patient for its antioxidant purposes, but using a key later to bind that copper is a good thing to do. Otherwise, it could just circulate and cause more issues.
I would say the same thing that question about copper toxicity and using copper pans, we could say the same thing about using cast iron pans.
I'm not against using cast iron pans, but certainly, that's not a source of iron. People will post that and other Instagram posts use cast iron pans. That's how you get your iron.
I know that's elemental iron. You don't get your iron by to eat on metal bars. You know, you get your iron from your food. So from organ meat, from vegetables, you don't get your minerals from elemental sources.
Those are toxic sources. So that's not how we get our minerals.
How often should I run standard labs? Well, that's another, it depends answer to this. So it depends on if you are your standard labs have been running normal.
And you're not doing anything different is for as things that would that would cause abnormalities. Let's say you're not taking medication.
That could cause issues with your liver markers. You're not taking fed vendors all that could cause issues with your liver markers.
Then you can spread those out. So it's all depends on, hey, my last labs were normal. Well, when were the ones before that?
Two months were those normal. Those were a little bit off. Okay, let's maybe go three months on these.
Or my last labs were abnormal. You had me run them again this month. And now they're still abnormal. We're going to still keep running them on a monthly basis. So it depends on what we're looking at what we're dealing with.
But in general, how often should anybody run labs if they were consistently normal? Well, if you have a major change of symptoms, you should investigate why you have that change in symptoms.
But otherwise, I don't think it's wrong for a healthy person with no diagnosis to wait a year, you know, to run labs to make sure everything normal. That makes sense. So you're just trying to use some reasonableness in your investigations.
But husband's HSCRP was elevated. And what that means is high sensitivity C reactive protein or some labs call it cardiac CRP.
And because when it when that fast test first came out, they thought it was going to be much more specific to cardiovascular issues, and you could argue that it probably is a little bit more specific to cardiovascular issues, but there's so many things that could cause elevated high sensitivity CRP.
Many inflammation in your body can cause it. Certainly cardiac issues. Well, you could even have dental infections causing, you know, hidden dental infections causing elevated CRP brain inflammation can cause elevated CRP Alzheimer's Parkinson's abdominal, you know, got issues can cause elevated CRP obesity can cause elevated CRP.
There's a lot of things that can cause that. So investigating other things, it's just like any any lab marker, it's not a standalone thing like you have this, that means this, you have elevated PSA, that's pretty much means you have prostate cancer.
Most markers aren't staying alone, you have to look at it in conjunction with other things as well. So I'm starting on hypermectored and bedbed bedbed is all what would be better for the liver if one has hormone positive breast cancer.
Tonka or a product with milk thistle. So I think the person's asking the question, if I'm on a fed bed is all or bedbed is all an hypermectored that has the potentiality of causing liver congestion and issues with the liver, what would be best?
Tonka product or a milk thistle product to help with that. I would say milk thistle because milk thistle is going to more directly support the site of CRP for 50 pathway with detoxification and I think that is the issue typically with with bedbed is all products is that the person just isn't detoxing it well.
So you don't have to detoxify it well. So I've had people on bedbed is all and they don't ever have any elevations and AST, ALT or alkaline phosphates that other people it directly affects it.
And they have to go off of it for a period of time and it really gets down to maybe genetics and maybe just you know other damage to that person's liver over time.
That you know we live 70 years and what damages are liver well our toxic load damages are liver alcohol damages are liver but really bottom line is our is our toxic load alcohol is a toxin to our liver and that could damage those pathways and we are not going to be as fast as at detoxified as someone who doesn't have those pathways damaged.
So I would say milk thistle but if you have toned cut at home already you can certainly take that as well.
You recommended the product clear in plan for me after my genetic test results came back all far away from food does one need to take it.
You don't need to you can take that with your meals there's that does not need to be taken away away from food you can take that anytime you can take that with your food.
Those are flavonoids which are all food based products what's the best time of day to take glutamate scavenger I can't remember if you suggested this because of the panic attacks I'm still having in the late afternoon at evening.
Yeah so glutamate scavenger I probably did recommend it for the panic attacks because I think we discussed the possibility of panic attacks and anxiety being tied to excess glutamates in the brain so remember so what causes anxiety what causes panic attacks what causes.
OCD issues what causes depression issues it's brain inflammation so depending on where that brain inflammation is what part of the brain their inflammation exists and it's going to give you different symptoms even pain can be from brain inflammation.
So remember your brain you have different lobes in the brain the front behind your behind your forehead is your prefrontal cortex it's your executor of the brain that tells the rest of the brain what to do that tells that's where your thought process is that's where your personality is.
But then that's where your decision making is that's why it's called the executive function of the brain and it sends messages back to your pre motor cortex and then to your motor cortex which performs function of movement if you're going to move your hand you have to fire back into those centers.
The OCD issue and the panic issue has to do with a deeper part of the brain part of the brain called the amygdala is there these are called more sensory parts of the brain that store memories that store
more primitive function in your body this is where your sympathetic and parasympathetic nervous systems are stored these are part of your autonomic nervous system mean automatic it's not something you think about you don't think heartbeat faster heartbeat faster or liver detox faster liver detox faster you can make your liver detox faster by your executive
prefrontal cortex function it's done by a deeper part of your brain and if you have inflammation in any parts of these centers of the brain you're going to have symptoms the outside top of your brain you have your pride alums that's what care that's what sends back sensory function so that's where you'll feel pain hot cold.
Stingling sensation if you have inflammation up there you can have pain elsewhere in the body I have knee pain all the time could it be cause from the knee itself you damage the knee sure could it be cause of inflammation in the brain yes I have nothing to do with the knee whatsoever so brain inflammation affects your whole body so panic attacks same thing there's brain inflammation
but the other thing I said about panic attacks and anxiety and OCD it can be because of neurotransmitter imbalance any times because of inflammation but that neurotransmitter balance would be excess glutamate the the excitatory neurotransmitters in your brain are glutamate as your primary one dopamine can be as well can serotonin can be as well
and epinephrine can be as well but glutamate is your primary one that can get out of balance and it tends to get out of balance partly because of our diet because our food sources are filled with glutamates exogenous glutamates that are meant to stimulate this pathway they literally put glutamates in food so that when you eat that food the glutamate connects to your tongue the sense of fires a glutamate sensation to your brain
and you get an excitatory neurotransmitter response to that food and that's what can make you say wow this is really good I just love this Chinese restaurant or whatever it is because of the glutamates that are in there stimulate that your neurotransmitters and your brain fire excess glutamate up tick your brain you get excitatory neurotransmitter function of your brain
and you think that the food tastes better though it's simply a glutamate response tricky huh well we have all sorts of exogenous glutamates in our food but we also can have defects on our GAN pathways where we convert glutamine which is an amino acid followed in all sorts of proteins
we can convert that to glutamate quicker with that defect and we can be more prone because of that to end up producing excess glutamate in our brain
and then we have we're more prone to OCD issues and panic attack issues then it can seem more complicated you have what you reinforce neurological pathways in your brain
by those pathways firing more often so the more you fire a pathway the more that pathway is reinforced I explain it as kind of like if you have a gravel road but it's being traveled on a lot
they're going to pain it and then they're going to turn it into a two lane four lane six lane highway that's kind of what happens in your brain when you when you are when that pathway is being fired so even in the past you're exposed to a lot of glutamates that OCD pathway or that panic attack pathway got
pained stimulating that that neurological pathway that then is more easily traveled because it's turned into a highway that is exactly what from a neurological standpoint
the simplest terms is how you describe PTSD as well so you had this horrible experience and then anything that triggers it triggers that experience again and you basically are repaving that pathway
so glutamate scavenger product it's called glutamate scavenger two that I typically recommend can help poll glutamates out of your brain was a very long answer to when should I take this so when you should take it is when you experience those attacks or if you know you start getting more of those attacks let's say at three o'clock maybe at two o'clock
an hour before is the time to get that into your system to reduce those attacks recently I heard that all you lose a replacement for sure is a replacement for sugar is this okay to use well treated cancer
and just general health yes it is so you can use all you lose and stir that in your coffee or use that and I just don't know what the what the like one to one ratio is
typically it's not typically it's not used like to make cookies or something like that because it would be quite expensive because it is far more expensive than just sugar that you buy in the store so but yes it can be used as a replacement in small things
there should you know there can be people can have some sensitivities to put that's fairly rare I have a couple models of burberry at home will this be good to add to my supplements while I fight horrible positive breast cancer
yes yep burberry there there there isn't any of the cancers that I would say don't use burberry burberry is great for cancers lot of research on burberry for cancer
and there is so many side benefits of burberry as well burberry can help lower your blood glucose burberry can help kill pathogens in your gut burberry is one of the best components to kill each pylori burberry is good to help with your blood vessels burberry is one of my favorite supplements because of that it is so well rounded cancer killer you know cardiac
cardiac helper H pylori pathogen killer anti parasitic antibacterial product it's a great supplement you mentioned during my last my appointment last week to keep you abreast of supplements that we are taking what's the best way to inform you of new things you're taking
so let's say you're going to another practitioner your other practitioners recommended supplements to you on a regular basis you can email those to me and if I think we need to have a talk about that then I'll just have you know informed ready to call you or message back that we should have talk about that
email them to labs L.A.B.S. at cutters clinic make sure you spell my name correctly C.O.N.N.E.R.S. clinic dot com so right on here labs at cutters clinic dot com would be labs in front of them
okay questions I see you sell LMNT in the cutters clinic store do you evaluate other sugar free electrolytes and decide that one was best
well to be honest with you there's some things that are in our store that I would recommend to patients so just be an honest
so we don't you know we try our best to to pull things out of our store that I don't you know because okay so let's say we carry designs for health products
so carry designs for health products is great so you know me or a staff person would would you know go through and put in all the designs for health products
into our store you know what the pricing of their new all of this it's a lot of work and I usually need some support in help in putting these things in now
when I have time I can go through it and like I don't want to sell that I don't agree with all every designs for health product that's why we don't have all of designs for health product in there
so it's the same thing with any of the other products that we have in there now I won't put in there typically a line of some moments that I don't like and I don't support
because I don't trust you know their practices and I don't trust you know the company itself so there's some companies that people ask for and we don't carry those
I think there's a lot of good nutritional companies out there now compared to just a few years ago where there was a lot fewer good nutritional companies
but that would be that I would vouch for every product that we have on the store so that's not how I want you members shopping anyhow I don't want you to go I'm going to look for this and I'm going to go buy this
and we get that often and sometimes I have to ask Megan to call you and say hey you know Dr. Hunter would recommend this not this
why you know sometimes people just search I get it they're just searching for a vitamin B12 and they can't remember the last one they had or something
or they are told that they need one and then they pick one that I wouldn't recommend for that let's use methyl products for an example
we have a lot of supplements that are methyl based because we have a lot of patients that aren't cancer patients
but often we will get one of our cancer patients typically at somebody that isn't done the Zoom calls very often and typically at somebody that we haven't talked to for several years
and they'll order a product and I might have if I catch it I say they say to Megan can you call XYZ and tell them that I would never recommend that for them
and sometimes they're ordering it for somebody else in their family I get that but I certainly you know even though I might have talked to that person for a couple of years
I don't want them taking something that I would never tell them to take so but I don't always catch that and Megan doesn't catch those things she's filling orders
so if you as a poor patient that stayed in touch with me and trying to follow what we're what we're recommending
what something else maybe for somebody else or a family member still it's a good thing to talk to me
and you can ask the question on the Zoom call like whoever asked the question about their husband has elevated CRP
so you can ask that question if we don't get too many family member questions on the Zoom calls
but for the most part I try to evaluate the majority of our supplements we have I don't know 5,000 skews on our store
so I don't evaluate everything and these companies are changing things all the time it's very hard so as far as LMNT recharge
I think that's a okay product I don't see that as a bad product I think it's a good product
I don't typically recommend that because I don't not typically recommend a lot of electrolytes for people
but that product I think it's a fine product designs for health has an electrolyte product as well
and I think it's literally the same so because an electrolyte product's typically just going to be sodium and potassium
magnesium it's just going to be a mineral product and you just don't want a poorly bowed mineral
and either one of those electrolyte products are just fine so when a person's thinking they have to take electrolytes
they often think that they have to take a product that's labeled as an electrolyte product
so electrolytes are going to be minerals so taking a good mineral is going to give you that electrolyte balance
unless your sodium is way off and you need to be taking sodium electrolyte products by themselves are typically created for the market of the athletic market
so some athletes that's working out three hours a day that's what like a paid three hours a day has a lead body mass of zero
and they need to keep their electrolytes up for their heart that's typically going to be the electrolyte market
most other people will they talk about wanting to keep up their electrolytes they're just going to take a good mineral product
and that's what I would typically recommend the reacted multiband or the our clear multiband product
next question I see I seem to have a stomach virus with cramping a diarrhea in oily stools silver, biotic, helped last week
but when I went off of it the symptoms are back
so viruses how do you kill stomach virus and stomach bugs?
well sometimes you got to kind of go through the course of it
we're always remember that you have a right machine at home so if it is a viral infection
running the viral programs are the way to go if you feel like you got some sort of food poisoning
then there's other parasitic and bacterial infections that you can run as well
so always go to for any type of bug that you might have at home whether it's strep or staff or anything like that should be your
right machine and then the other things that will help kill those things
hey we talked about one called burberry today that's great for your gut and got this biosis
make sure you're taking a probiotic that can help with balance your macrobiotic
and yeah try to get back on track
next question when I originally started with you I had been taking a D3 plus K2 product
and I had that I had and you said I should continue taking it I used that product up
and I'm wondering about the D3 K2 product that you sell
okay I'm going to use this as an example so first of all this is the right thing to do ask me
so when I what I'd like my favorite D3 product is our D3 complete
oh it's called ADK complete because it's all the fat soluble vitamins in one thing
so the ADK complete gives you 5,000 I use a vitamin D, vitamin K, vitamin E in the delta
total tree at all form so I think that's the best one out there
and I'm using this as an example as we just had somebody this morning or last night
purchase the cell core brand and cell core just came out with a D3 K2
and of course cell core everything cell core has also has full vacant cubic acid
and somebody one of our patients who we haven't spoken to for a while
purchase that and I have to call I have to tell Megan to call her and say that's not what I would use
I mean cell core is great products but it doesn't mean that their D3 K2 is
would be my recommend I'm never going to recommend that to patients
of course if it tests for them I may but just from a knowledge base I would recommend that
so I recommend that ADK complete for your D products because it has all your fat soluble supplements in it
I've been using the LM and T because the sodium my sodium has been low and it has helped it could back up
yes so if your blood sodium is low which can be you know you can have issues with blood sodium
for different reasons and then you need to be taking a sodium product so that using
then using electrolytes would be fine and those are good I mean they're not the designs for health
would aren't any better than that so absolutely so why would a person have low sodium
a person have low sodium because of medication they're taking different medications
could affect sodium levels because it affects a hormone that causes you to spill sodium
into your urine and you had to pee it out all your sodium a adrenal fatigue can cause low sodium
other if you have excess adema you're going to have low sodium because your sodium is going to go into your adema
taking the diuretic is it going to cause low sodium
and things like addison's disease which is a disease of the adrenal glands it's going to cause low sodium too
regarding the ADK complete product would I follow DOSID recommended as a product
I would take at least one a day if you're stable and you're doing well I would just do one a day
that's 5,000 I use a day and I would base it upon your blood test of your vitamin D level
if your vitamin D level is below 80 that I would probably take two a day until you could get it over 80
and then you could go back to one a day if your vitamin D level is 150 that I wouldn't take it at all
you really want to keep your vitamin D levels between 80 and 150 for a person with a history of cancer
anybody else don't have cancer still I think your vitamin D level should be 50 to 150
but you'd base that on your blood work why would a person have high sodium
mine was a couple points high last time which has never happened before
well there's really two reasons why you'll have high sodium what is adrenal stress
so remember I said low sodium could be adrenal fatigue so your adrenal glands
you could be under stress your adrenal glands are functioning well
but your adrenal glands are hyper stress that can give you high sodium
if your adrenal glands are completely fatigued then you'd see that at a adrenal stress test
as just a straight line on the bottom remember the adrenal stress test where you have higher
cortisol levels at certain times of the day in the morning then it dips down at night
it has that nice little curve well somebody who's got adrenal fatigue or adrenal burnout
they have no curve it's just straight line across but a person that has just adrenal stress
can be that whole they can have a normal curve but it can be elevated
and that can cause high levels of sodium but really the most common cause for high sodium is dehydration
so dehydration not drinking enough water or drinking too much water
so remember dehydration is from you're not drinking enough water or you're like out in the sun
drinking coffee out in the sun or drinking alcohol while you're playing golf
on a hot summer day you could easily become dehydrated and that can cause issues
you can have high levels of sodium that can affect your heart etc
but a person could be dehydrated because they drink too much water too
so remember those are the two possibilities so dehydration most common
adrenal stress is up there too
I'm watching a mole on my face and not sure if I need to go to the dermatologist
is there something that I can put on it to prevent it from turning into anything bad?
well when you have it on your face that's another thing because you know if you had a mole on your arm
you could put black sap on it to make sure it's not melanoma or sarcoma
if it was then you'd have this reaction it would become painful and you'd have to follow us
and protocols in order for that to come out as an escar
if it's on your face and it is melanoma or sarcoma you could do the same thing
but you're going to end up with a great big scar on your face you better know what you're getting it to beforehand
if you think it could be a basal cell carcinoma very common on your face
you could use oregano oil or frankincense or other essential oil
oregano oil I would say as you know we've seen a lot of people with basal cell carcinobus
but you should google pictures of different types of cancer to get an idea
basal cell carcinobus is they all pretty much look the same
have a little shatiness to them if you looked at a picture of Google you'd say oh that's what it looks like
or yeah it's not that if it is a black dark colored mole then it's more likely a mole
or if it is a cancer then your choice is to you could still try an essential oil
and a reason why I say you could try that on your face is typically not going to leave a scar
or anything like that you could use curcumin cream as well we've used a curcumin cream
make up your own curcumin cream with just a cream base of choice hopefully
organic with some powdered turmeric mix it up together and you could dab it on your face
but just remember it's going to stain could stain give a little yellow skined stain
and it will stain your pillowcase and things like that
so just remember curcumin is very you know stains your clothes and things
those are some things to look at if you go to a dermatologist you know with a dermatologist's experience
and looking at cancers he or she may say oh that's just a moment worry about it
or they may say well we should buy up see that then you're talking about your open up the can of worms with that
so it's just your choice if you look at it closely and you can kind of gauge it with some pictures on the internet
you can get ideas of what a can of can't be and then you could use the most gentle approach
you'd be doing essential oils or turmeric cream on it any other questions
alright well we'll end for tonight thanks everybody for being on
and we will talk to everybody
next week alright bye bye